do you think that Joe Biden should run
for re-election in 2024. it's either
that or Trumper and that would be just
devastating for the world why because I
think that he is a rapist what makes you
think he's a rapist the because he has
raped a woman and it's in court right
now he didn't get charged for rape
he was found liable for battery and
defamation but there was no rape charge
oh you gotta go now
we have to go here we have a couple of
trumpers here wait is this is this what
happens when you can't defend yourself
in an argument
we got a couple of trumpers here how did
she know that she's got a couple of
trumpers here because she was talking to
people who were calmly stating
indisputable facts that's the sign of a
Trumper